Doesn't it look delicious?
It's amazing.
Oh my God, who is
going to eat this?
Me.
We never look at the
past in a nostalgic way.
We look at the past
in a critic way
to get the best from the
past into the future.
Taka, join me please.
Here's my buddy, Taka, my
brother in my restaurant,
Osteria Francescana.
We are rated the best
restaurant in the world,
but it's much more than that.
It's about feeding
people with emotions.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
I want to teach you the way
to evolve classic recipes
from traditional Italian cuisine
and bring them into the future.
This is like the pasta
is talking to you,
when it's saying eat me, please.
Eat me.
I am here for you.
How you can improve
tradition-- this
is panettone in a
traditional way.
This is a panettone you
can make from the leftover.
Can you imagine?
But this is 100 times
better than this.
You know, in cooking
you always have
to keep the door open
for the unexpected.
I want to tell you a story.
At the moment I had to
create pesto for 120 people.
We are out of pine nuts.
What are we going to do?
Bread crumbs.
We put bread crumbs
instead of pine nuts.
This is like, exactly how to
evolve tradition-- tradition
in evolution.
Don't throw away anything.
You can use everything
and make it even better.
Ask those ingredients
the right question.
They're going to answer.
Cooking is an act of love, and
it's bigger and it's deeper.
So you, you're going to
explore where you come from.
You're going to
explore your memories.
Your palate is
going to talk to you
and it's going to
tell you where to go.
It's up to you because
you are expressing
yourself, your experience,
your own flavor.
I'm going to show you how
to be free to imagine,
to dream, to transfer emotion.
Sono Massimo Bottura
e questa e la mia MasterClass.